alors
l'or qui est très énergique
je gagnais manière en guerre
avec ça je suis venu ici surtout pour
découvrir pour changer mon cas c'est mon
quotidien pour découvrir des gens pour
trouver d'expérience pour voir de beaux
paysages
voilà vous pouvez poser les sacs se
canalise à jour
j'aimerais proposer des sacs c'était
bizarre
car
qui est là
solène bonjour j'ai souvent une fleur à
l'oreille de toute l'année moi je vais
l'appeler dame nature solène si elle est
très proche de la nature et c'est un
vrai petit bonheur et une vague de
fraîcheur
la bienvenue à tout le monde vienne je
vous présente le jeune est à voilà on
vérifie un petit coup et on sent
effectivement ça va tourner entre 12 et
13 kg il est assez bourrin il fait 12 12
second kg apparemment donc par mois il
est assez lourd à tanger prime le strict
minimum
voilà on va regarder ce que ça donne
le sac de couchage avec saveur du sac
c'est bien quand il fait beau
s'il se met à pleuvoir bon après on a un
point de chaud et tout mais c'est quand
même moi je préférerais voir le tapis de
sol en dessous elle sacs de couchage ans
ou même si on doit bosser un peu je suis
attaché au confort des personnes pas
seulement au niveau du couchage mossi
faut au niveau de la marche c'est sicile
5e à l'équilibré si s'il n'est pas réglé
la bonne hauteur ils vont être en
difficulté ils vont plus pouvoir
apprécier ce que j'ai envie de leur
faire apprécier c'est à dire la beauté
des paysages les plantes pour profiter
sereinement du passager oublier le poids
du sac
il ya une quinzaine de kilomètres ya
environ 500 m de dénivelé
c'est bon on y va allez allez zou
pour ceux qui n'avaient pas vu encore le
lac naturel de gérardmer pas de barrages
pas de l'igas et c'est les glaciers qui
nous ont offert ce joyau il ya un peu
plus de dix mille ans pour notre balade
pour aujourd'hui sur cette petite buteur
face vous voyez un arbre un petit peu
particulier
c'est une tour en bois donc on va longer
une part que le lac jusqu'à la base et
on va monter vraiment pas rapidement
tout droit dans cette petite sur cette
petite vue de quoi
finie la rigolade là on change de monde
autant le monde
c'est bon ils sont frais comme des
gardons donc on arrive sur le plateau on
va sans fil et un petit peu là il à
l'observatoire convoyer tout à l'heure
depuis le lac
un petit peu fatigué quand j'avais un
puissant estimiez de courtage du sac
doit dire donc ça serait bien sentir
comment ne sais pas pourquoi il est si
l'eau en fait parce que j'ai pas mis de
choses vraiment inutile dans ce ca donc
le sac de couchage et le sac l'human son
son lourd après voilà j'ai la même chose
que les autres j'ai regardé ce qui
l'amène à l'heure ça qu'on a je ne sais
pas la particularité c'est que la cour a
été édifiée par les script est solide
mais elle ne supporte pas un nombre de
personnes excessif donc on va faire deux
groupes pour pouvoir monter on peut pas
monter tous ensemble je sais pas du tout
le vertige et elle a l'air plutôt solide
mais j'essayais de faire bouger la tour
eiffel verte' donc tout va bien donc qui
saura les 4 juillet volontaires dont
j'avais donc c'est une tour pour vosgien
faut baisser la tête quand on monte a
pas de grand
vous pourrez regarder déjà toute petite
info le suicidaire donc on voit bien
l'église vous aurez partie d'un centre
du village de l'artère walchi dégâts
zone est déjà bien à gauche il ya
quelques jours
et en forêt ce décret très connu dans
les vosges trouve à retrouver pour
stopper tout juste en face
ce genre de photos derrière chez mes
parents
tiens qui tous ont des formes
il n'a qu'à soi
avoir des pistes est protégé par
l'ensemble du manteau forestier
donc pas de soucis il commence à être
dans les plus grands dans les plus
massifs la tête au moins et ouvrant quoi
etc c'est une des causes assez
importante de mortalité des arbres en
forêt c'est la prise au vent
alors quand il ya des gros coups de voir
en été mais surtout surtout en hiver
quand le pôle la neige mais tu vois un
peu de neige sur là où vous avez vu là
où tu es la tête des sapins quand elle
est bien grosse quoi ça peut retenir
énormément de neige quoi donc derrière
un petit coup de vent et se bouffent les
principaux hasard ce qui domine en fin
de compte la végétation vont être soumis
à la casse quoi on se trouve qu'il est
vraiment génial plus il adore nous faire
partager toutes ses connaissances sur la
région basse et le but aussi je pense
et puis
non il est super bien parce qu'en plus
je dis rien ils essaient de nous faire
passer aussi le message qu'il faut aussi
randonnée par paix par plaisir en fait
et donc ça ça compte beaucoup dans sa
vision des choses et puis moi je partage
assez bien cette vision là aussi donc
d'ailleurs ma
je crois que la dame avec un t-shirt
violet je m'appelle plus son nom monique
wayans muriel ok j'ai senti ce matin que
d'un groupe que muriel était peut-être
un peu limite physiquement elle s'est
vite essoufflée quand on a grimpé pour
arriver à l'ère des pique-niqué elle
était souvent derrière donc qu'elle va
être vite fatigué par rapport à nous que
tu sais pas trop on verra bien tu crois
que c'est surtout le portage qui qui
fait que je suis un petit peu à la
traîne
et puis bon aussi certainement le manque
d'endurance à ça c'est sûr maintenant
c'est vraiment la première journée donc
forcément d'un petit peu mal partout je
pense qu'après il faudra il faudra voir
on aura l'habitude je veux dire de de
porter ça sera déjà un petit peu moins
moins dur le deuxième jour quoique je
pense que les muscles vont se réveiller
aussi donc c'est pas gagné
on a bien duré une bonne mise en jambe
on a bien mérité lautrécois j'ai fait ça
parce que je ne suis pas du matin mais à
prendre du poil de la bête
ça s'appelle la carmi faut le frotter
comme ça dans les doigts tu peux mais
d'où vient d'être dégagée encore plus
d'odeur c'est luc harvey on utilise
surtout au niveau des graines on va
décoller un ça va arriver avant la nuit
c'est soit j'espère raisonnable fou
quand même faut quand même qu'on marque
la vallée du bouchot célèbre pour les
moules de bouchot bien évidemment
l'important c'est que cette sauvegarde
et ses articulations genou hanche et de
compresseurs amortir par les bus pour
faire rentrer 3
une petite gâterie de la montagne la
forêt oxalis alors qu'un pour ceux qui
connaissent pas les prendre oxalis comme
moi vous la mâchouiller et puis au goût
vous allez me dire à quoi ça me fait
penser à des souris alors d'autres notre
avis l oseille très bien l'oxalys et le
nom de la priorité aux ailleurs fait une
grosse voilà c'est désaltérant c'est à
dire qu'on l'apprend la mâchouiller
lagarde en bouche c'est vraiment que de
choses qui est il moins sympa à voir en
bouche quoi désaltérant quand il fait
des belles journées comme ça allez zou
je continue
nathalie nathalie nôtre puisque nathalie
va vous faire déguster ces potions
magiques avec ça vous pouvez ça vous
requinque et c'est reparti pour une
marche de réussir derrière donc ceux des
vertus anti inflammatoires oui c'est
parfait pour nous intégrer pâle donc ça
fébrifuge ainsi alors les anciens
disaient que ça faisait sortir la
maladie
voilà moi j'aime bien les plantes et
puis j'aime bien en faire profiter les
autres
donc forcément je vous donnerai la
recette donc la fleur de sureau noir est
reconnaissable par rapport au sureau
rouge parce que les grappes qu'elles
sont en fleurs ou en fruit tombe comme
ça mon amie charlène gens l'aiment la
poule est très gentil et pourquoi ça se
conserve un nom parce que mon général
c'est un peu plus chaud bon alors des
volontaires pour la cuisine dans cinq
minutes
dans cinq minutes ou à ça peut être un
petit peu pas de souci on arrêtait on
vous attend pourrait faire un petit
arcarde orties pour commencer leur pain
alors quand on peut et des orties on
prend juste
la sommité tués dans non ce sais pas
c'est pas bien méchant
en fait ça s'applique parce qu'elle est
petite aiguille qui explosent à tout
contact
je m'attendais pas du tout je ne
connaissais pas grand choses dessus donc
j'apprends des choses alors il ya quand
même un truc pour pas se faire piquer
quand on continue comme quoi c'est
d'expirer ou ne pas respirer du tout à
ce moment-là vous ferez pas piqué des
nuls 1-1 ap newey ou expirés
si vous êtes fatigué pendant une
randonnée vous pouvez prendre une
feuille ou la replier vous presser un
petit peu ça c'est pour casser les
aiguilles et vous le mettez sous la dent
je vous garantis que vous qu'après au
point de vue vous retrouverez votre
énergie
voilà on a 2 bal donc on cap
ben j'ai escaladé pourvoir attrapé du
réseau parce qu'en fait on est en
contrebas là et on est complètement
isolé il ya on est coupé du monde qu'on
fait et demain matin ce qu'on vous
propose c'est de confier vos portes à ce
qui évitera de les perdre
dans un premier temps que vous pourrez
bien sûr récupérer dès la soirée venu
pas beaucoup de gens qui m'appellent à
n'importe quel moment puisque je fais
soit de l'animation de soirées soit du
guidage de pêche j'ai passé mon diplôme
et un mois et bombe à la saison de pêche
est bientôt finie mais par contre
l'animation de soirées
aujourd'hui on m'a appelé pour une
soirée dans quinze jours hier on m'a
appelé pour une soirée il ya dans un
mois c'est des appels que je ne peux pas
manquer quoi puisque puisque c'est mon
gagne pas mais quelques années j'aurais
réagi exactement comme jérôme et je le
comprends pour ça mais maintenant c'est
bon je suis lancé donc lâché en vacances
donc mon portable hp l'état n'y a aucun
souci pour ça le soir je peux allumé
pour la famille et la copine mais c'est
les vacances sont professionnels donc
y'a pas de soucis c'est vrai que là à
midi
moi j'ai fait la connerie de répondre
à un coup de fil et ça m'a pas plu donc
je pense qu en autogestion je lui dis
juste un appareil photo ça fait des
chouettes photos et ses pratiques
donc je vais le garder mais je vais moto
gérer donc je te fais un gros bisou et
puis il ya bientôt la claquette châu je
suis puni à 40 ans voilà ont puni comme
un enfant le droit de téléphoner pendant
la journée l'air chose à te remettre
pour la journée en espérant que je le
retrouverai ce soir je me suis surprise
en fait d'oublier que effectivement dans
mes habitudes j'ai besoin d'avoir mon
portable dans la poche pour me rassurer
et ça fait vraiment du bien qu'assez des
habitudes et et va être c'est une très
bonne initiative que pierre ce que
pierre nous a proposé c'est vraiment
très bien et je renouvelle l'opération
demain
on peut parfaitement se nourrir avec des
orties avec les plantes qu'on trouve
dans la nature
et après on lâche tout ça et puis après
on m'offrait d'après votre gourou 15h en
afrique oui c'est sûr le hachoir science
le plan alors une berceuse sur tout ça
sous ses airs de 2,2 de son tir n'est
pas marjah mais la cuisine c'est
vraiment pas mon truc
il ya des 13 il ya des spécialistes de
la cuisine dans le but donc profiter de
leur savoir faire cette semaine
je suis moi pour manger c'est soit des
plats préparés
soit un sandwich fait sur le pouce à la
rage comme ça moi c'est beaucoup de
plats micro ondable deux minutes
micro-ondes tu perces le dessus et puis
tu enlèves après fitch et mons à quoi ça
n'a aucun goût c'est ainsi pin encore
une fois voilà la nourriture j'aime
beaucoup la manger j'aime pas la ferme
c'est pas c'est pas une de mes priorités
dans la vie ça me gêne pas de pain bien
manger en fait je vous donne à chacun
une part de d'ortie mélange avec les
oignons et après c'est à vous à votre
goût parce que voilà les orties ce même
chose ça c'est à vous de rajouter
un peu de vent et de soja un peu un peu
plus ou moins de moutarde 1 donc un vrai
et puis vous goûterez chacun et puis
vous verrez que ça change selon qu'on
rajoute un peu comme saint-amand voilà
j'y suis allé par petites doses et le
début j'en ai rajouté après il n'a
commis beaucoup qui ont voilà c'est ça
la différence mais après ses goûts et
les couleurs
oui c'est effectivement un poivrier je
leur ai fait deux péchés tournée et ça
ne marcherait pas forcément je fais pas
ça a été un oubli de ma part mais c'est
pour montrer à quel point je n'utilise
jamais de pauvres y est par exemple
enfin si j'utilise du poivre mais c'est
pas dans un poivrier c'est pas moi qui
le qui le mou quoi elle est déjà prêt
c'est ça reflète tout à fait mais mon
expérience avec la nourriture faut que
ce soit tout près faut que ce soit
rapide
moi ce que je ne supporte pas dans la
nourriture dans le fait de faire la
cuisine c'est med +2 allez on va dire
dix minutes pour faire à manger
nathalie tu veux goûter j'ai préparé des
tartines pour les collègues on m'a fait
des tartares d'ortie lassus caucase ou
peut-être est bon
mais oui je suis très surprise par va
par le goût ça dégage ouais c'est
vraiment agréable
globalement je suis je suis agréablement
surprise parce que je n'ai pas du tout
avoir cette seconde en fait ouais
tartare d'ortie
j'ai très peu l'habitude de cuisiner
avec des produits comme ça de la nature
va déjà se cuisinent pas énormément pour
commencer ensuite c'est vrai que j'ai
pas du tout l'habitude de cuisiner des
produits comme ça un petit peu
particulier
cueillie même la nature donc j'ai trouvé
ça super intéressant ce soir on a
attendu beaucoup pour manger mais
samassa m'a pas dérangé ne m'a pas
dérangé parce que je n'avais pas faim
pas énormément fin par contre j'ai vu
que les autres très fin ce soir en
attendant le repas
donc je sens bien là dans les muscles
j'adore marcher peut marcher 20 bornes
six jours mais c'est vrai que porte et
c'est vraiment pas mon truc là c'est sûr
que je vais un petit peu mangé les
premiers jeux pour tous pensent mais du
ravin si ce qu'ils veulent je vois qu'il
ya des assiettes
moi je suis surpris qu'on dorme dans des
tipis je pensais qu'on allait vraiment
dormir dehors
ou mieux avec un petit feu de camp qu'on
allait faire jeter mais enfin je moi je
m'attendais vraiment à ce à quoi dans
les duvets bonjour à tous du soleil pour
ce lundi sur la lorraine les nuages
présents ce matin se désagrège peu à peu
et les éclaircies s'imposent dans un
ciel pas totalement bleu mais presque
les masters l'avancé le matin
c'est agréable nuit tout s'est bien
passé à peu humide mais dans l'ensemble
tout va bien café près des tartines sont
en fait j'ai bien dormi que penser dans
le camp même tuer bercé par de petits
ronfleur lorsqu à viroflay nom est super
moyens
mais dans l'ensemble ça passe à ce qu'on
m'a dit ça à verser quelques personnes
donc c'est ce n'est pas ce que tu es
riche turc sa salle après jetons
classement mais combien il contraste
entre le mythe et un peu nomade un peu
rustique quoi est au contraire un bon
repas viendront jr c'est intéressant
envoyé sur les panneaux chalet ducharme
et en fait on sait pas du tout ça en
plus et d'oracle
et on finira la semaine ça me dit
normalement on est encore les neuf là
haut